what's going on everyone super excited
it's breakdown what we're talking about
today
which is the kind of four big you know
chapters in the growth of a business so
zero to a million dollars a year
one to ten million dollars a year ten to
thirty million dollars a year and then
thirty two hundred million dollars plus
all right
and this was this is now taking me a
long time to figure out
painstakingly so hopefully uh this will
be a value to you it's kind of
interesting though because
when i learned more about this it's hard
to even learn things without having the
context
and a framework to apply them on right
like unless you have a business
it's hard to understand all the
bottlenecks because none of it's real
for you so this will probably be more
for the people who have businesses
but if you don't have a business then
you know please enjoy um that being said
zero to a million really really simple
it's just
one product on one channel
very simple all right that means you
learn how to figure out how to sell one
thing
on one channel all right a channel would
be like cold email
facebook ads instagram ads youtube ads
referral partners you know what i mean
uh all off of organic you know
earned media so all of these are
different channels that you can use to
acquire customers
and the reason people get stuck in like
100 300
ish like range is usually because they
still haven't really nailed this it's
still haphazard they get clients from
here and there
but they don't have a reliable system
for acquiring customers all right
literally that's it zero to a million
it's a reliable system of acquiring
customers
and doing it and most people also get
stuck here because they have
personal problems like they're they're
they're super angry and they hate
themselves and they're not good with
people that's that type of thing
like they a lot of times they have the
right system they execute it and then
they crash themselves because they have
they're you know sleeping with their
customers or sleeping with their you
know employees just like it's just crazy
interpersonal drama
is in this range but the business from
the business standpoint it's very simple
it's just
one product on one channel and then you
just make the math work so it's not a
thousand dollar thing got to sell 100 a
month
that's it that's all it is at this point
though right
million ish two million ish a year now
mind you these are rough you know
sometimes it might be one to three it's
just the range here
but once you're in that kind of one to
three range getting to 10
is an entirely different thing all right
getting to 10
is multi-products right
now an important note here is that
you're not starting multiple businesses
right it's going to be cross-sells
and upsells all right so that's
in another way is creating a value
ladder it's creating a it's creating a
back end
right it's what's the what's the next
level of service that we can provide
these people what's the next thing
they're naturally going to want to need
or want and need after buying our
initial product right
and so thinking through this like it's
most people who
are in this million dollar range are
like man what else should i sell them
like
you're asking the right question exactly
the right question that's what you need
to do to get from one to ten all right
now from 10 to 30 in mind you uh it's
multiple products
and uh and depending sometimes it's
multiple channels
all right um you can you can kind of do
it either way
either single product on more channels
or you can do multiple products on
single channel or you can do multiple
like
that's a little bit wiggle e but i would
say the easiest for most people is just
focusing on
their back end which is the cross cells
and upsells what are the things that
this person is actually going to need
next which is going to increase our ltv
so basically what happens is
you're selling the same same number of
units as before like i was saying let's
say you sold 100 people at that
at that 1k ltv but then you you you 4x
your ltv and all of a sudden or 5x or
ltv
right this is how it happens you 5x4 ltv
and it becomes 5k
over the lifespan and now you're at 500
000 a month and then because you're at
500 000 a month
you can start going to another channel
because you can afford to do it because
your ltv's higher so basically what ends
up happening is you learn how to cheaply
acquire customers on one channel that
you're very well suited for
right then you extend and expand the ltv
of that customer
by introducing a backend and then once
you have that back in it now opens up
other traffic platforms
uh or channels that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to afford but now that
you have a superior backend you can now
go broader right that's kind of how it
works from a
from a business day to day standpoint
all right so zero to a million one to
ten million
all right next line here is 10 to 30
million this is another one where people
you know massively screw up uh which is
professional design
professionalizing the business all right
uh
and this is honestly really painful and
it's it's hard to do
and i'm thankful that i had mentors
early on that were like this is what you
need to do now because i probably
wouldn't have said this is the next
thing
but what ends up happening when you're
at like 10 million million a month type
you know
ranges then like the thing that made you
special your special sauce here which
may have been a lot of you as the
founder
um is it starts to get diluted out right
and then you have customer complaint and
customer support issues and then
you know things it's just like you're
basically still a really big small
business
uh at that 10 million like you don't
have the systems the infrastructure to
build
more on top of because it's still like
google sheets and and you know
and trello boards you know it's just
like it's just craziness to try and
manage this
and so this is where you have to hire
some more corporate people and this is
you know what every entrepreneur fears
more than anything right is that we fear
bringing in these corporate suits you
know who just gonna suck the life out of
you you're like i started this business
to not have to do that but you know what
every massive business in the world was
started by a founder
right who probably didn't like that and
the reason big businesses run like
business
big businesses is because it's the only
way to run big businesses like
you have you have to have corporate
structure you have structure you have to
have hierarchy you have to have
you have to have hr you have to have you
have to have these things in place
so that employees feel more comfortable
but also so that you're you're protected
from a liability standpoint
right uh because honestly once you get
into this range you become a target
right this is where lawsuits start
coming in this is where lawyers and
contracts start mattering and
all of this stuff right um and so
professionalizing the business
especially from hr
legal and accounting standpoint comes
here and then the it systems
all right so this is really like really
strengthening the ops of the business
the operational infrastructure
because what this does is that it makes
all of these things that we learned how
to upsell before
it really makes them methodical right it
becomes people get the same product
every time same product every time
and so then client happiness goes back
up and things are good
now the problem is the people who come
in at this 30 million
a year you know are getting from 10 to
30 is that they're not innovative at all
if anything they stifle innovation
because they want things to go through a
certain way and then they just
they you know you want to choke them to
death um but you have to do it all right
but the thing is is that if you go these
are all like pendulums right
if you go too far in that direction then
you lose the creative energy and the
drive of the business
uh because you kind of have these suits
that are trying to control everything
all right
and so this is the gap that i have
struggled to make is going from 30
million
plus to two to a hundred million dollars
a year and so i'll share what the
mentors that have shared this with me
um hopefully it'll be useful for you but
yeah i mean we've been we did 28 37
32 i think the last three years uh so
we've just really been stuck at this
level
and it's because of this last piece
right because the thing that made us
right was frankly was was me and the
entrepreneurials
like drive and i'm not saying i'm the
sole responsibility obviously our team's
amazing
and they're the reason this works but
it's saying like what's the you know
what's the soul
right and so what ends up having to
happen
is that at this level you actually have
to have more
souls you have to have more people with
the juju
right more people who can drive growth
who can take
initiative and seize opportunities right
and so this is kind of the entrepreneur
versus the intrapreneur dilemma and i'll
break this down for you
so an entrepreneur is somebody who wants
has entrepreneurial tendencies within
within a corporate structure
right um an entrepreneur wants to own
their own thing
and i have made horrible mistakes so
many times
um hiring entrepreneurs and treating
them like entrepreneurs when in reality
i should have just never hired them
right um because they're going to tell
you no i you know what i had a business
before i don't have any interest in
doing that
and so you really have two kind of two
outcomes that happen here
either have the entrepreneur who comes
into your business lost their juju
right and now just sits in your business
and continue complains about how they're
not getting paid as much as they could
make on their own but they can't make it
on their own which is why they're
with your business right or the person
is right
and can make more on their own and so
they come into your business basically
regain their confidence
start doing well and then take as much
of that business with you as they
possibly can
and so either way the outcome's poor and
so i had to learn that one
the hard way multiple times in our
business which is don't hire
entrepreneurs
all right what you want to do is find
entrepreneurs all right these are people
who
um really prefer they love the
entrepreneurial drive of like driving
growth driving change
taking initiatives building out new
things innovating right
um but they don't have the same appetite
for risk
right and so because of that they like
having this kind of safe place to go
experiment and do all this stuff but
they still know they're going to get a
paycheck
every month now that paycheck's variable
but even if they you know suck they're
still going to get paid
or paid well right and so this is what i
have
i've been trying to you know imbue into
our business right now and it is working
um is is putting on intrapreneurs in
places where
they can drive change because if you
really think about it
what ends up happening is that your
business becomes
a conglomeration of smaller
sub-businesses right if you listen to
jeff bezos talk about
his directors she actually calls them
ceos he's like oh that's ceo of that
business that's ceo of that business but
they're all within
amazon right but they're kind of sub
ceos and this is the thing is like you
need
you can only provide so much willpower
and spirit to a business once it gets to
this size because there's just so many
people that you just get deluded
like your spirit your care your drive
your vision just get diluted throughout
an organization and so you need
you need heads that can kind of
reinvigorate
the business and drive new uh
innovations and so
what ends up happening is the way this
the structure looks like and the way it
shifts to i'll show you real quick
[Applause]
is it shifts to something like this all
right so you've got your
your core here right which is the the
operational infrastructure that we put
in place from 10 to 30 million
so this is your um this is your your hr
right legal uh
i.t finance right
that's your that's your core all right
that's the core ops of the business that
has to happen or everyone goes to jail
right
people need to get paid you need to pay
taxes contracts need to be signed
you know crms i'd see all that kind of
stuff right and then what ends up
happening
is that off of that spoke right
you have profit centers right and inside
of a profit center you're going to have
product and you're going to have
acquisition all right
so acquisitions marketing sales and then
product right and so
inside of these these are all identical
right
product acquisition right product
acquisition you get the idea right
and so each of these become profit
centers
right for the business and so these
things can all roll into you
while this all rolls into someone else
right from a from an operational
standpoint but this is really how the
business would function right
and so this is where you might have you
know product line you know number one
right product line number two product
line
number three right and each of these are
going to satisfy
needs for the customer ideally when
you're enumerating these product lines
is
you want to use the existing resources
that you have and capital and
infrastructure
to create products that are similar but
different right so
for example if i were if i were like
because obviously we have a coaching
business
uh for gyms so if i were you know
expanding pro like
uh services then what's one of the
things that we we've added in so we
we added in um uh we call it a boiler
room
so this is something like a lot of a lot
of our gyms were asking for more help
with sales and so we're like well how
about we just train you guys like we
train our team like our team drills
every morning
we do boiler room that's how that's how
all of our guys start our day so why
don't all of you just
if you want this additional service
because not everyone wants it
you can pay a little extra for it and
then you can bring all your sales team
and we can drill your sales team
and so they get pumped up and the nice
thing is something like that just shows
such clear roi
um to a business that it's like oh my
god i would never stop paying for this
so it's really sticky right
and it's high margin so it works it
literally works for everyone right and
so it's like we have our core like let's
fix your business
service and with the existing resources
we have which is these are the skill
sets and
the individuals that we have that work
for us we know that we could create
this product line and i'm calling a
product line but service line
um with little investment right we don't
have to do a ton of stuff there
right whereas when i started the
supplement company that was a huge
undertaking
that probably wasn't the wisest decision
i i was fortunate that we were able to
maneuver it and now it's a very very
healthy business
but it took i mean but it was very hard
and i probably shouldn't have done it in
that order
right i should have thought like okay
well they also want um someone to run
their ads for them so that's going to be
our done free agency side so we're going
to add that in right
and again each of these like this
hopefully this makes sense to you
delineating these things it's like these
are all types of services
that a customer who comes in would
naturally also want in addition
and these can be upsells that will
increase the ltv the customer while also
making your own
your own service stickier and helping
them basically you want to you want to
envelope the customer with all the
things that they want
that being said you have to have the
operational know how to do this and this
is where people get screwed up
all right is that when they create these
product lines they
start trying to manage both and then
they start trying to manage all three
and then and then they start another
business and then it gets even crazier
right
and so this is where people massively
screw up and so
until you have a true leader and i'm
saying
a true leader this person has to be as
smart as you are all right
running a new product division i would
not recommend
doing it which is why business growth is
slow because it's all about the people
like that's the hard part every
entrepreneur's biggest problem is they
can't find good people
it's the hardest problem in the world
and it's also because we need to be
better people to attract better people
and also manage better people because if
you think about it
if i were an omnipotent being if i were
god right
i could probably perfectly manage
everyone to become an a player
so that's a belief that i try and use
it's like if i were a perfect
leader and a perfect manager i could get
everyone
to you know surge forward and and and be
the best
right but i am an imperfect leader and
i'm an imperfect manager and so i have
to find people
that have a little bit of battery
included uh to get the result that we're
looking for so hopefully this makes
sense in terms of how you structure the
business and how it scales
you know at this point this would be
like your zero to
zero to a million would be here you go
zero to ten million
maybe with product line one or product
line two added in
right which then allows you to scale
your acquisition so acquisition goes up
on each of these things because the
total ltb is higher
and so this is ultimately how the
business scales all right so quick
recruit for everyone
if you're zero to a million you don't
need to worry about anything you gotta
sell one product and one channel that's
it you gotta get good enough at it that
you can do it repeatedly in your sleep
once you have that then you're like okay
we got this unlocked now we can sell
multiple products these people so i need
to find somebody who's good
put them in charge of this help them
build out a product line that is an
entrepreneur not an entrepreneur
um and and then we'll cross-sell them
into this additional service
or or product line that doesn't require
a ton of capital investment what else
could we provide these people that they
have been asking for
right from 10 to 30 million it's like
all right now we need i.t we need legal
we need hr we need compliance we need
all of this other crap because you
become a target
straight up you become a target in the
business all right and so um you
professionalize the business but you
can't lose the entrepreneurial spirit
and to not lose the entrepreneurial
spirit is when you hire entrepreneurs
and then you put them in chartered
product lines all put around the central
spoke
of the infrastructure for operations
so hopefully that makes sense hopefully
that valuable if you're in the zero to 1
million
range then just don't get distracted
with shiny objects focus on one product
on one channel it's all you need to do
keep being awesome i'll catch you guys
soon bye